aux etats unis le discours très
galvanisant de george bush devant le
congrès hier soir le président américain
aux bestiaux n'est par les
parlementaires a juré solennellement à
l'amérique et au monde de gagner la
guerre contre le terrorisme à washington
etienne leenhardt
il est entré comme un boxeur remporait
sur un ring décidés à en découdre et
galvanisé par une foule toute acquise à
sa cause
george bush le savez ce discours devant
l'amérique toute entière était sans
doute le plus important de sa carrière
politique il y faudrait à la fois
rassurée et contre-attaqué se comporter
en président mais aussi en chef de
guerre notre peine s'est transformée en
colère et notre colère en détermination
que nous livrions nos ennemis à la
justice ou que nous fassions justice ni
même justice sera faite
ils ont rendu hommage aux victimes en
faisant un triomphe à la jeune épouse
d'un passagers qui s'étaient jetés sur
les pirates de l'air pour tenter
d'éviter le pig l'ont applaudi à tout
rompre le maire et le gouverneur de new
york pour leur courage et leur
détermination à reconstruire ce qui a
été détruit et l'on se leva encore pour
saluer le premier ministre de grande
bretagne et son soutien sans faille leur
est venu d'engager des représailles et
d'exiger de l'afghanistan des comptes
livré aux états unis tous les
terroristes qui se cachent sur votre sol
ces exigences ne sont ni discutable ni
négociable
de l'avis unanime jamais george bush qui
va devoir maintenant passer de la parole
aux actes n'étaient apparus aussi
présidentielle et l'on ne pouvait
s'empêcher de penser hier soir à le voir
serrer dans ses bras l'un des chefs de
l'opposition démocrate qu'il ya six mois
encore cet homme élu dans la douleur
était la risée d'une bonne moitié de
l'année